so I've toxins channel before about the
importance of visualization have
discussed how essentially a working
memory boils down to form a
visualization have talked about how a
planned movements and how we can use
image training in order to improve our
athletic performance and I've discussed
how in some ways visualization may be
the very foundation for our thought
thanks to something called embodied
cognition what if you could boost your
visualization skills what if you could
improve your ability to visualize
pictures and images sounds and events in
your mind's eye or if you could retrieve
memories in greater detail what if you
could plan events that way solve
problems and increase your creativity
well as you might have guessed you
probably can and I'm gonna show you a
technique you can use to do all that in
this very video so when you hear people
say that your working memory has a limit
of seven plus or minus two really this
is over simplifying things because in
fact you're using a form of your working
memory all the time when you visualize
anything so when you're in a room you
know where all the objects are around
you all the people are this is a form of
working memory you're holding that
information in your mind's eye you're
visualizing that space and that's how
you move around it without bumping into
things and that's how you can navigate
quickly to what you want to find in
sports when you want to pitch you use
your working memory in your
visualization to know where everyone
else on that pitch is likely to be both
on your team and on the opposing team
when you kick or throw a ball use a form
of visualization to predict its
trajectory and then you use your working
memory to guesstimate that trajectory is
you run towards it in a fight use
visualization in order to predict their
movements in order to plan your own
movements so improving your
visualization skills will massively
improve your physical ability and your
performance and athletics and computer
games and all sorts of other things but
it can also improve your ability to
solve problems and to come up with
creative solutions because when we count
the creative solution what we do we're
imagining possible outcomes possible
ways of approaching a problem and we do
that by picturing that thing in our
minds eye when you think of making an
app you picture that app in your mind's
eye you picture yourself using it when
you think of building something or
drawing something you picture what you
want it to look like first and then you
execute on that and we can actively
choose to use visualization in order to
solve problems as well so there's a
little riddle that I heard when I was
reading
about this and it goes like this there's
a monk and he's churning up a mountain
to find a temple at the top he wants to
stay there to meditate so he makes his
journey and it takes a whole day that
first journey on the way up he travels
for 24 hours going from the bottom to
the top varying his speed taking Briggs
for lunch having a nap etc until he gets
there then he stays at the temple and
does his meditation or whatever else for
one more day 24 hours and then on the
third day he makes the journey back down
the descent and this takes exactly a day
as well another 24 hours
and he takes breaks along the way he
varies his speed and he stops for lunch
the question is is there a point in time
on day 1 and day 3 where the monk is in
the exact same position on the mountain
so maybe at 4 o'clock or 2 o'clock is
there any point during that day where
the monk was at the exact same point on
the mountain so if you try to logic this
out and use your logical rational
reasoning then you might come to the
conclusion that no the monk would not
have been in the same position at any
point during the day because he's used
different speeds on the way up
he's paused for lunch he's taken naps
he's gonna move that different speeds so
of course he's never going to have been
in the same place at the exact same time
on either day however if you use
visualization to solve this problem then
the riddle becomes a lot more clear so
picture the monk walking up the mountain
and picture the monk walking down the
mountain now overlay those two images
and of course the two versions of the
monk must meet at some point on their
journeys they must cross paths as you
can see then they must have been at the
same point on that mountain at the same
time at some point during their journey
so you might have come to the right
conclusion using normal rational
thinking but as you can see you can make
the conscious choice to use
visualization as a form of thinking as a
form of problem-solving and sometimes
that's better suitably come up with the
correct answer more effectively than
other forms of thinking and this is
something that Einstein knew very well
that Einstein believed and we can see
this when we read about how he came up
with this theory of relativity and of
special relativity Einstein said that
when he came up with a theory of special
relativity he pictures himself falling
off of a roof and looked around to see
how that might look and when he came up
with relativity he pictures himself
traveling on a beam of light and then
visualized what the rest of the world of
the universe would look like to him
at that point it was so intuitive in his
visualization skills were so great he
was able to come up with the correct
answer and unlock the mysteries of the
universe just by picturing what his
brain intuitively knew would happen and
I've shown had some physical changes in
his brain that might have explained this
ability to he had larger regions that
were dedicated to visual spatial
reasoning and he also had a larger and
thicker corpus callosum which is a band
of neurons that crosses the left and
right hemispheres of the brain and
connects them so he would have been
better at whole brain thinking in it
ever using his visualization skills
along with other forms of reasoning in
order to come up with more cohesive and
comprehensive answers to problems so how
can the rest of us improve this ability
well I found technique online by a guy
called wim Venga which apparently can
help us to improve our visualization
skills and is called image streaming
basically what you do with image
streaming is you go and find a quiet
place to sit down in a kind of
meditation type setting and then what
you're going to do is visualize things
happening and you're not going to force
it just going to allow it to come and as
you do that you're going to describe
everything you see as it happens in as
much detail and in as much multi-sensory
detail as possible as you're going often
you're supposed to use a recording
device of some sort or even tell someone
else's a song there listening and
recording what you're saying and you do
this for about 10 minutes and you just
allow these images to come and as you do
that you should find that with each
session with each practice your ability
to visualize improves and you start to
see more and more vivid and
multi-sensory images and you become
better and better at describing them and
using them in a useful manner so like I
say you're not to force these images and
if you're someone who struggles with
visualization to begin with you might
find that nothing much really happens
when you close your eyes in which case
there lots of ways you can prompt
something to happen for instance you can
force yourself to visualize just that
first thing or one method that's
recommended is to rub your eyes and then
to use the phosphenes that show up in
order to get you started you turn those
patterns into an image in your mind
either way the most important thing is
that you just keep trying at it and
don't judge yourself this isn't
something you can fail at you're just
going to allow this images to come as
they do and then describe them and like
I say it need to be multi-sensory so
describe the temperature the texture how
you feel the wind against your skin if
you're visualizing a place for instance
or the speed of the moon
by doing this you're creating a more
vivid and rich imagery in your mind
because when I say visualization I'm not
really just talking about visual imagery
visualization is anything that you hold
in your working memory any form of
activity in your brain that is
counterfactual so it can also be sounds
and it can also be feelings and
sensations that's why I say the
phonological loop this is when we play
music or phone numbers back to ourselves
in our head we want to improve all of
that so you want to use all your senses
in this visualization practice within 10
days or less you should start to notice
improvements and what you'll find is
that you start to use visual thinking
like this more often
day to day so you're you become better
at remembering things because it can
picture where they were where you left
them in your mind's eye so hopefully
you'll lose your keys you could become
better at solving problems by picturing
things in your mind that's storing
information in a visual sense and coming
up with scenes and ideas I found that I
used to come with loads of great ideas
for apps another was having something of
a dry spell since I've been doing this
practice I've count with two quite
compelling ideas for apps and I feel
like this has really helped because I am
someone who's quite visual I like this
kind of thinking and reasoning I do feel
this tool has helped me with that and I
think that in time and maybe using other
exercises as well improving your ability
to visualize could be one of the biggest
things to train one of the biggest
improvements you could see through any
form of brain training or physical
training I'm also very interested in
lucid dreaming which as of yet I haven't
managed to achieve but I wouldn't be
surprised if image streaming was a
practice that could potentially improve
this and I will say this since trying it
my last few dreams have been a lot more
vivid and I'd say I've also been a
little more aware during them so who
knows I'll report back if I find
anything interesting on that front
so I'm definitely interested to hear
what you guys find with it so check it
out give it a go let me know what you
think in the comments down below and if
you want more information on this then
check out the link in the description
down below just to note I was interested
to know with you really easy to talk
about what you're seeing if you could
just practice using your visualisation
whilst I'm sure that just using your
visualisation would have some benefits
what I found when doing more research
was that the reason you're talking and
having it recorded is that they improved
a verbal fluency which is also a useful
thing to train and
that's the part that is thickening the
corpus callosum because you're using the
language sensors and the visualization
centers and this might be what is
actually giving you more ability to
utilize those images and those
visualization skills so do do the
talking part as well and what I've been
interested in trying is writing it down
instead of talking because talking
something you can't do anywhere feel
talking to yourself on the bus like that
you will definitely get some funny looks
whereas you can write something down on
a laptop visualizing and nonno that
anything weird is up again I think
there's this isn't the be-all-end-all I
think she's just a very interesting
technique and I think training
visualization in general is certainly a
worthwhile endeavor so I'd love to hear
if you've got any tips or methods in the
comments down below I'd do my best to
read all your comments and I really
appreciate them because I've learned a
whole load from them and there's lots of
ideas that I'm going to be checking out
more thanks to your suggestions so
please keep them coming really
appreciate it and in general really
appreciate the support and your watching
this channel and liking the videos means
a great deal to me and I'm really
excited about how this channel has been
growing lately so yeah thanks a ton stay
tuned for more like this and I'll see
you next time bye for now